now with the NHS coming under
unprecedented strain this winter nearly
half of parents say that they don't feel
confident about getting quick day-to-day
medical care for their children a Paul
by the website mums Ned also found that
a third were unable to get a GP
appointment for their child in the
previous three months well I'm joined
now by the chair of the Royal College of
gp's Professor Camilla Hawthorne very
good morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us first perhaps it's useful
for you to give us an idea of the kind
of pressures that GPS are under give us
a sense of what an average gp's working
day looks like
okay I think first of all I really
wanted to say how sad we are to see
these survey results because we want
parents to have confidence in the NHS
and in NHS services and certainly GPS
and their teams pull out all the stops
possible to see children
um to make sure they get timely and
appropriate care
so a GPS day nowadays is unbelievably
busy
um it's common for GPS to see between 40
and 60 patients in a day which is really
not sustainable and sometimes not very
safe I was talking to my brother-in-law
yesterday who was a GP in Farnam and by
tea time he'd already dealt with 140
patients which is way more than I've
ever heard before so it's a really
really busy pressurized atmosphere it
starts at about seven or eight in the
morning it can often go on till eight in
the evening GPS will then go home have a
quick bite to eat and then get onto
their laptops to do all the paperwork
that's accumulated as a result of seeing
all these patients so it is at the
moment we're working absolutely full
tilt now it isn't because GPS are not
seeing patients because they don't want
to they really do want to and it's a
source of enormous frustration for us to
feel that we're not able to do our job
in the way that we would like to and
that's because there just aren't enough
GPS due to years of underfunding
and poor workforce planning and in a way
the covert pandemic followed by strep a
followed by influenza is just
highlighting the nature of the problem
so GPS are feeling stretched according
to this poll a large number of people
feel that they struggle to get an
appointment for their children so what's
the solution
well the solution really is to have a
bigger Workforce you know we need at
least 6 000 more GPS that's what the
government Manifesto said in 2019 to be
delivered by 2024 so they're way behind
on that because in fact the numbers of
GPS are actually dropping so we're now
about 700 short of where we were two
years ago we're not increasing in
numbers and a lot of that is due to
burnout and people leaving the
profession early and what we really need
is better retention strategies for GPS
to keep people in the job and working
seeing patients in the way that they
would like to do
well yes and in fact in the mum's net
poll 86 said that they blamed the
government for the crisis in the NHS do
you agree then
uh yes I think that it's been a number
of factors really
um you know you can't blame the
government for covid-19 or for strep a
but those have really just highlighted
the underlying uh shortage in Workforce
and we've been uh warning the government
about this for at least a decade
probably longer that numbers of GPS were
um were falling and that this was going
to become a crisis and also that in
order to run a functioning Health
Service you need a robust general
practice you need to have a good Primary
Care Service and there's very good
evidence from across the world that
countries that have a good functioning
Primary Care Service have a much
healthier population
we're seeing walkouts by nurses and
ambulance staff is there a mood amongst
GPS for industrial action do GPS want to
strike
no I don't think they do at the moment
um it's not really our function as a
Royal Medical College to comment on
terms and conditions of um of of work so
it's not really within our remit to
comment on this and we wouldn't normally
discuss it but um speaking anecdotally
I've not heard of a concerted move
amongst GPS wanting to go on strike at
the minute
however beyond the strikes amongst
nurses and ambulance workers do you
think it's likely that we could see more
widespread walkouts amongst other
healthcare workers
I think there is just so much pressure
um on Healthcare staff right across the
NHS and it's really important that Staff
feel able to do their job properly to
the standards that they're trained for
and under the right conditions and that
is really I think what is underlying a
lot of the dissent and discontent that
we have currently
and and I wonder if you have have a view
on the ongoing dispute with the nurses
uh we have seen reported this morning by
the Times newspaper that uh Pat Cullen
the the head of the RCN the the nurses
Union at saying that she might be
prepared to meet the government halfway
would look at an offer of around 10 even
though the nurses Union has asked for 19
originally what do you make of that and
do you feel that progress could be made
I really hope so I think no NHS worker
wants to strike it doesn't matter who or
what you are within the NHS resolution
is the best thing for everybody
concerned and of course particularly for
our patients it's not for us to get into
details of what this might look like I'm
afraid
um but I think whatever happens it's
absolutely essential that we all work
together to minimize the impact on
patient safety
well Professor Camilla Hawthorne a chair
of the Royal College of GPS we really
appreciate your time this morning thanks
so much for talking to us thank you